joining us now is the shadow justice
secretary steve reed hello to you thanks
for joining us on the program this
morning uh talking talking about party
gate there so let's talk about um beer
gate at the time i think it was march uh
your leader said that because the prime
minister was being investigated by the
police he should resign your leader is
being investigated by the police
the the difference here is that we knew
at that point that the prime minister
had been breaking his own laws
well we've seen we've seen allegra
stratton if you remember the prime
minister's press secretary
um in that clip that was circulated very
widely laughing about a party that had
gone on the night before prime minister
the prime minister came down to the
house of commons the next day it was a
wednesday so it was pmq's and he told
the country he shared their anger
what had been said it later turned out
the prime minister was at that party so
he had been breaking the law he'd been
lying and ultimately he got fined for it
there was a world of difference between
what was going on in uh downing street
where we now know 50 people have had
fines including the prime minister for
breaking the the lockdown rules that the
prime minister set uh for the country 12
different parties investigated beer beer
and alcohol wielding in suitcases
invitations issued the world of
difference between that and what
happened in durham where kia stammer and
his entourage who are up there for a
campaigning
event stopped to have some food and a
drink and then continued with their work
absolutely no equivalence but what
kirstarma has done and i think it's the
right thing to do
because he wants to show that all
politicians are not the same he has said
that if he were found to have breached
the rules he would resign now he's
adamant he hasn't i absolutely believe
there was no breach there's no
similarity between those two scenarios i
just described durham and what was going
on at number 10 downing street but he
would resign if that was the case
what that shows is that kierstama
believes that lawmakers cannot be law
breakers the prime minister
believes that the laws are for the
little people and if he breaks them he
should get away with it you cannot have
in a democracy the leader of our country
setting rules that he thinks don't apply
to him because what if you're a criminal
uh and you're you're a criminal and
you're being asked to break to obey the
law um and you you can just throw back
well the prime minister doesn't obey the
laws that he sets why should i obey the
laws it just sets so much
the wrong message
to our country we have to have integrity
at the heart of public life kirsten has
showed he has integrity where the prime
minister i'm afraid has none
he's a former director of public
prosecutions he knows that syllables
matter he said
because the prime minister was being
investigated by the police he should
resign and yet he is not abiding by the
same code of conduct well as i just said
the circumstances are very different we
knew the prime minister had broken the
rules we know kirstama hasn't so
we had to well surely we have to wait to
find out what the police think we're not
we're not judging jury are we we're not
we're not judging the jury and you're
quite right that we have to wait to see
what the what the police have to say but
it was clear the prime minister was
breaking the rules and indeed he's had a
fine he may have a sequence of further
fines for for what he's done i don't
believe kirstama will get a fine
actually because i don't believe that
what happened there was anything other
than a work event which was entirely
entirely within the rules that is so
different from issuing uh party
invitations and bringing in booze on the
sound system
the point is that he is saying that the
prime minister should have resigned
because he was being invested yes but
the difference is we knew the prime
minister was breaking the rules
we didn't know we do i mean the police
but we knew he was in breach yeah but
kia stammer was judging what the police
might decide well right
he was a former director of public
prostitution you can't do that yes
that's right but but but but we know
that the difference is immense holding
regular parties at number 10 downing
street during the lockdown that the
prime minister pretended he hadn't been
at and then it turns out he was he stood
in prime minister's questions and said
he was angry at what allegra stratton
his press secretary has said about a
party which he said hadn't happened and
we later find out he'd been at it he was
lying through his teeth to the british
public and it is that disreputable
behavior that brings all of politics and
all politicians into disrepute kirstama
is sending a clear message that he is
not like that he has integrity if he is
issued with a fine for breaching the
rules he will resign the prime minister
should adopt exactly that same position
if he wants to uphold the integrity of
standards in public life how do you feel
about the northern ireland protocol
being ripped up
well this is this is a really dangerous
move for the for the government to want
to make at this stage and we need to
remember
how the northern ireland protocol came
into being in the first place boris
johnson negotiated it it was part of the
brexit deal that back in 2019 the prime
minister uh came and said was an
oven-ready brexit deal it was a good
deal for britain um everything in it was
sorted and resolved and we must vote for
it and indeed the public did go out and
vote for that brexit deal further down
the line it turns out as as as as often
as this prime minister he'd lied he said
there would be no border down the irish
sea over his dead body there only would
be a border down the rsc over his dead
body in fact there is a border down the
irish sea because um the protocol
requires there to be one the protocol
that boris johnson signed if he wants to
happen if he something has to happen and
if he wants to get rid of it he has to
negotiate its negotiators way around
that he negotiated it in place he needs
to negotiate it out if he does what he's
threatening to do now this is where the
dangerous part of it comes in okay if he
rips it up he is ripping up an
international treaty uh that will damage
the uk's reputation internationally but
it will also damage the economy because
he could end up by triggering a trade
war with the european union our biggest
trading partner on the planet
which will add further misery to the
economy which is already stalling we've
already got the highest inflation the
lowest growth of any major economy he
would make that worse but there's a
second consequence and that's president
biden has said that if the british
government boris johnson does anything
to damage the good friday agreement
which by ripping up the protocol he
would be damaging that's the agreement
that brought peace to northern ireland
then the united states will not have a
trade agreement with the united kingdom
either so the other biggest um economy
on the planet other uh other than the
european union also will not have a
trade agreement with the united kingdom
does boris johnson really want to
isolate
our economy does he really want to enter
trade wars with two of our biggest
trading partners and further damage
economy at a time when people are
already finding it difficult to make uh
ends meet we've got a high tax and low
growth economy under this conservative
government because they've not invested
for 12 years if they further cause
damage to our economy then the living
cost of living crisis we're seeing now
will get worse and worse and worse over
years to come i can't michael go says
that won't happen
well
he's absolutely wrong because if you if
you sign an international treaty if two
countries in the world sign an
international treaty and one of them
rips it up that state becomes a pariah
why would anyone else on the planet
leave a word that something has to be
done because it's not working it has to
be negotiated now it's not working and
it was boris johnson that negotiated it
so first of all i'd like to see boris
come and stand in front of the house of
commons and apologize for telling us
that this was a good deal when in fact
it's a botched deal because he signed it
and he pretended it was good when i
suspect all along he knew that it wasn't
then i'd like him to sit down with our
european partners and negotiate a way
around this that removes trade barriers
with uh between great britain and
northern ireland but does not breach the
good friday agreement and the key point
in that is that there must not be
a border on the island of ireland
because it was that border that
triggered the troubles that lasted for
decades and resulted in so much um loss
of life nobody wants to go back to that
now boris johnson got us in this mess
boris johnson can negotiate his way out
a bit and labour also feels then far
more than just trade that potential
there shouldn't be a border on the
island of ireland at all well the the
good friday agreement to which the
united kingdom is a signatory says that
there should not be um a hard border
there's a border obviously between the
northern ireland part of the united
kingdom and
my point is should northern ireland be
part of the united kingdom well that is
a matter for the people of northern
ireland to determine
well the belfast agreement is absolutely
crystal clear on this that the fate of
northern ireland is in the hands of the
people of northern ireland and that's
exactly as it should be it was a key
part of that agreement and there should
be a border referendum if they want it
it's entirely up to the people of
northern ireland it's not for me it's
for the people of northern ireland to
decide that uh and that final thought as
far as the queen's speech is concerned
uh was it as me was it meaty enough for
you
no it was really thin gruel you know i
was genuinely shocked when we when we
got given well we we we heard prince
charles reading out the queen's speech
and then saw coppers of it afterwards
we're in the middle of the biggest cost
of living crisis in a generation
people can't afford to make ends meet
they're having to choose between heating
their homes and and eating and feeding
their families and there was nothing in
it to help we had a few weeks ago i
think i talked to you about it at the
time the uh the chance of a spring
statement that left the average
household 2 600 pounds a year worse off
now given the pain that is being
inflicted on households at the moment
you would think in a big set piece um
event like the queen's speech putting
out the legislative agenda for the
coming session potentially two years
there would at least be something of
significance in there about the single
biggest crisis we're facing but there
was absolutely nothing i mean what we
would have liked to have seen
um is is plans to give people real help
now and the windfall tax that my
colleague rachel reeves first proposed
on the energy companies that have made
three four billion pounds surplus
profits above and beyond what they
expected a windfall tax on just a part
of that could cut household energy bills
right now by up to 600 pounds real help
when it's needed but from this
government we got nothing out of time
good to talk to you thank you very much
for joining us on the programme thank
you